in other news short-term interest rates
are higher this morning meaning many
Americans face increased borrowing costs
the Fed hydrates yesterday by a quarter
point to a range of two and a quarter
percent to two and a half percent that's
the fourth rise this year in the highest
level since 2008 the Dow closed down
almost three hundred and fifty-two
points after the announcement it was the
lowest close of the year CBS News
business analyst Jill Schlesinger is
here with how that rate rise affects you
good morning good morning so the New
York Times breaks it down great I think
this morning because it says it makes a
difference whether you're a saver or a
spender if you're a saver who's got
money in the bank you're getting higher
interest you're doing well right if
you're a spender who say let's have
$10,000 on a credit card payment how
does this affect them borrowers are most
significantly impacted especially with
credit card rates which by the way are
on average about 17 percent maybe more
so for an average credit card borrower
that might mean a few extra dollars
every month but if you've got a huge
balance outstanding it could be a big
difference
other things impacted new auto loans so
you're go out and get a new car might
see a higher price maybe over 5% you
might see private student loans start to
rise adjustable rate mortgages some of
them adjust on an annual basis you might
see a higher price there and for your
home equity lines of credit those start
adjusting pretty quickly like 30 to 60
days so people could start paying more
for the money they've borrowed and Jill
it seems important that because the Fed
is said they're gonna keep rising rates
they think the economy's strong they're
worried about inflation the warnings
you're giving about rate increases there
there might be more so you've got a long
term plan it's not just reacting to this
one oh absolutely so if you are looking
at an average credit card balance you
know you have to pay it down here's your
incentive the Fed itself said two more
quarter points next year it's not
written in stone but you know you have
to do that put that on your new year's
financial resolutions we'll do that next
year but I want you to be very clear
that it is going to impact you but again
as you said bianna for savers it's
fantastic if you are a saver all of
these rate increases 9 over the last
three years have finally gotten those
interest rates up on
savings I looked at CD rates two-year CD
rates now finally poking over 3% great
news especially if you're a retiree
isn't it kind of a yin-yang because the
stock market's going to go down well
here's the good here this is actually a
very interesting thing because vast
majority of investors economists
analysts did expect that quarter point
increase yesterday so why did the market
sell-off the big reason is that during
his press conference chairman Powell
really didn't make people feel better he
said yep we're gonna probably do - next
year and we're on it and it almost seems
like automatic and investors were very
concerned because they felt like if
you're on some automatic program that's
not good for stocks it's also rare that
you have the president stepping in and
giving his views on the feds decisions
as well maybe that's confusing investors
yeah I mean look I think that the
president doing that it's not really
impacting Powell and in some respects it
may be putting his back up against the
wall Fed officials are not are really
not usually guided by politics although
look they got a report to Congress twice
a year so it is important right Jim
thank you always good to have you here
thank you